vous savez que depuis plusieurs années
maintenant les voitures électriques sont
annoncés comme une alternative aux
voitures polluantes ce sera absolument
formidable mais sont-elles vraiment
aussi écologique qu'on le dit les
journalistes de tout compte fait sur
france 2 ont enquêté plus chères à
l'achat mais avec des économies à la
pompe un coût d'entretien moins élevé
une voiture électrique permettrait à l'
usage sur quatre ans de réaliser 15%
d'économies par rapport aux modèles
essence équivalent mais est elle
vraiment écolo pour la fabriquer il faut
aller chercher des matières premières
rares aux quatre coins du monde
en bolivie c'est le lithium son
extraction détruirait des sols et
contaminerait l'eau en afrique
l'exploitation du cobalt dans des
conditions inhumaines financerait des
conflits armés en asie dans les pays de
l'est aux états unis les usines de
fabrication de batteries seraient
responsables d'une importante pollution
de l'air
l'ademe a rendu un rapport public une
voiture électrique est au final moins
polluantes qu'une voiture thermique elle
émettrait l'équivalent de 9 tonnes de
co2 contre 22 tonnes pour une voiture
traditionnelle
alors malgré tout au final on dit que
c'est quand même moins polluants mais
pourtant s'interroge sur le fait que ce
soit nul de l'électricité donc nucléaire
le fait que y ait du lithium à
l'intérieur et que donc la fabrication
même de ces batteries pose question
qu'est ce que vous en pensez gens bien
moi je pense qu'on est en train
d'oublier le sens des priorités
c'est à dire qu'on est en train de
basculer dans le tout écologique là à
l'heure actuelle semble content qu'il ya
plein d'autres problèmes à régler et là
c'est l'illustration selon me dit ça va
être moins polluants mais en réalité ça
pourrait être plus polluants et c'est
comme ça pour tout est en fait je crois
qu'on est tous sous les avec ce genre
d'histoires on n'y arrive plus on
comprend plus malgré tout est ce que
vous imaginez que c'est une première
étape et que c'est une alternative qui
vous semble le laisser l'impression
générale ça donne ça c'est qu'on a envie
d'acheter une voiture électrique mais
quand on entend reportage comme celui là
on se dit mais au fond est ce que je
fais bien et est ce que dans 20 ans on
va pas me dire ce contenant des voix
l'attention permanente ces familles
dites moi franchement je suis content de
ne pas avoir le permis
stark est là mais je sais mais
maintenant on va faire quoi on va se
promener en carriole ou en poney non non
c'est plus quoi faire on sait plus quoi
acheter on sait plus comment faire pour
être bien avec l'environnement
donc ça c'est dingue et moi j'ai un peu
par effectivement quand vous disiez que
dans 20 ans nous disait mans vous êtes
tous plantés dont vous êtes tous des
plans c'est un fric monstre le pour
changer de voiture pour rien on nous a
dit le diesel maintenant du diesel etc
etc
caroline bah oui non mais on se
trimballe ray avec un poney qu'on ne
trouverait en tout avec toutes les
données
je dirais encore que ce n'est pas la
bonne solution vers ya toujours un ton
dramatique a parlé de l'avenir et c'est
ce qu'il faut retenir moi je pense que
c'est que c'est quand même moins
polluants
neuf tonnes contre 22 tonnes point à la
ligne donc pour viser un premier pas il
est français mais pas celle dans ce
calcul
évidemment qu'on a mis les problèmes
environnementaux que constitue la
fabrication des batteries au lithium
ça y est c'est déjà compris dans le
chiffon qu'au lieu de prendre un air
dramatique plutôt pourquoi ne pas dit on
vous dit on voit le verre à moitié vide
et pas le verre à moitié plein
d'habitude on nous fait stresser on nous
angoisse et on nous et on auprès des
petits si beau jeu vous fait encore du
tour on n'a rien pris en compte du tout
on fonce dans le mur c'est la prochaine
catastrophe environnementale a carrément
mis d'accord ce qu'elle soit carrément
pourquoi parce que si on a le même lot
de voitures thermiques de voitures
électriques dans 30 ans 20 30 ans on va
se retrouver à devoir construire dix à
quinze réacteurs nucléaires en plus
c'est pas possible on le sait donc
aujourd'hui on nous incite à foncer vers
électrique et on n'est pas capable et on
le sait aussi
mais c'est pas de souci tout le monde
nous parle de l'électrique on y va et
votre calais tient mieux en france dans
les rues ses clés va falloir faire autre
chose on n'est pas prêts au niveau des
batteries oui après agen cervélo ce
qu'il a dit il aurait dû se recharger un
jeu
[Applaudissements]
l'attitude est ce que vous pensez de ces
voitures électriques au delà du fait que
leurs prix et en plus exorbitants
ça c'est encore un autre un autre débat